everywhere I go I see his face you gonna
be a next Iron Man now well no I don't
have time I'm too busy doing your jobs
oh I'm kidding I'm kidding look keep up
the good work because I am going on
vacation so good hey sorry I'm late
happy look nice thank you you too thank
you
new dress yes it is hot you know what
just happened
[Music]
[Applause]
two weeks in Europe is gonna be great
I'm just gonna enjoy my trip
Nick Fury just hijacked our summer
vacation
[Music]
hi everyone its charlie we're getting
ready for spider-man far from home but
in addition to a bunch of trailer scenes
that did not wind up in the movie they
just revealed a bunch of other really
cool deleted scenes that will break down
the video so we just did this top 10
style there are no spoilers in this for
the movie this is all about stuff that
either got cut out or stuff from the
trailers that did not make it into the
movie so no worries no spoilers we're
doing that IMAX ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a spider-man comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this starting with number 10 there's
a whole part of the movie like a solid
ten minutes at the beginning that they
had to cut out right as Peter was
getting ready to actually go on his
class trip to Europe you can divide the
movie into a couple different parts one
part is funny high school comedy the
other part is a really big superhero
action film so one of the reasons why
they cut so much out at the beginning is
because they felt like it just slowed
things down like they wanted to ramp
things up to crazytown as fast as
possible but during these scenes they
called it peters checklist all the
things that he had to do before he could
leave New York City so a lot of this you
see during the trailers like I included
that clip at the beginning of this nine
there's a scene of him patrolling the
streets of Queens in the iron spider
suit in the weeks and months since the
end of Avengers endgame you see a little
bit of them coming back to school in the
Avengers end game end credits scenes
with all the different Avengers going
their separate ways like you have Thor
going off with the guardians of the
galaxy you have a spider-man reuniting
with net leads for the first time so you
know that they've been back at school
for a little while at the beginning of
the film initially those scenes were
just meant to be him trying to go back
to being normal friendly neighborhood
spider-man
after going to outer space like Nick
Fury says bish you been to space but he
still had the iron spider suit upgrades
so he was a way more hardcore friendly
neighborhood spider-man showing a little
bit of the signs of the emotional
breakdown in the PTSD thus setting the
mood for him to need that quote-unquote
vacation I just want to take a little
break number 8 the next part of his
checklist was him picking up his new
passport like you see during the
trailers because five years ago so he
needed to renew it anyway if you look
here big easter egg the year he was born
is a little bit different but his
birthday is the same day that amazing
fantasy number 15 was released the very
first appearance of spider-man in the
comics pretty
cool in terms of birthday Easter eggs I
wouldn't be surprised if you found that
a lot of the Avengers heroes had
birthdays on the date of their first
comic book appearance number seven next
deleted scene was him visiting mr. Del
Mar's new bodega at the new location to
pick up some supplies for the trip just
really casual scene with him checking in
since the last one was blown up by the
Shocker and his crew during spider-man
homecoming with the vultures black
market suit our weapons
mrs. Delmar if you look in the
background behind mr. Del Mar's counter
there you can actually see newspaper
clippings of spider-man's more recent
saves from before Avengers infinity war
and Avengers endgame because he's still
wearing the old stark tech suit in the
pictures
so mr. Delmar confirmed is a huge
spider-man Stan just like Flash Thompson
6 there was a scene of him having to
sell a bunch of his vintage Star Wars
toys to get cash spending money for the
trip Kevin Feige in the director had
some funny jokes about this they said
that when they were filming Tom Holland
was a little confused by some of the
things they had him do during this scene
because Tom Holland is not a big star
Wars fan and has not seen any of the
original trilogy movies before she have
spider-man selling all these vintage
Star Wars toys they're actually worth
some pretty decent money but Tom Holland
doesn't understand their real world
significance like why would this be
worth a lot of money Wally's in the
process of haggling he takes back his
Lobot figure like no I can't sell that I
guess maybe because spider-man is a big
fan of the Lobot character or maybe
because that particular action figure
was worth way more money but the people
on set had to explain to Tom Holland who
Lobot was and why he was an important
character for some reason within the MCU
Lobot is an important figure to
spider-man maybe it made him think about
Tony Stark part man part machine with
the arc reactor make all the theories
you want about why Lobot would be a
really important character to spider-man
5 one of the biggest parts of that
montage that got cut was him taking down
all these mobsters you see in the iron
spider suit
it's the Manfredi crime family that he's
helping capture with the police most of
you will probably remember that the
Manfredi crime family is led by Silvio
Manfredi
aka Silvermane so this means that
Silvermane is an MCU character even
though they cut this scene they release
it with a lot of the blu-rays so I still
think of it as canon to the MCU so
Silvermane exists in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but we don't know
what he looks like or how old he is or
if he's already trading in black-market
shatori weaponry like the vulture was I
wouldn't expect full-blown cyborg
Silvermane to rot anytime soon though or
for him to flip out any magical D aging
tablets they actually did the character
during the 90s animated spider-man
series so you can watch that
you're really a big fan of the
Silvermane character for this is
actually pretty cool captain britain was
cut from an early version of the movie
there were a lot of rumors early on
about him possibly having a cameo now we
know why but the idea was is that they
were going to be spending so much time
in Europe and London during the movie it
made sense that they would reference
some British Marvel superheroes so
that's why they wanted to initially
include Captain Britain the cool thing
is though you'll remember the captain
Britain was already canonized in the MCU
during Avengers endgame there's a scene
during the 1970s when Captain America
almost gets caught by Peggy Carter when
they go back to get the tesseract he
sneaks into her office and then she
walks in on the other side of the glass
talking about an agent Braddock who is
Captain Britain in the comics there were
also rumors about the Black Knight
possibly being a Marvel character but
he's from the Captain Britain comics so
maybe the Black Knight rumors just spun
out of the Captain Britain rumors three
know the big deleted scene early on when
they were making the movie the class
tour group was supposed to visit new
Asgard in Norway on the seaside sort of
a post Avengers endgame follow-up to the
Thor Valkyrie and Hulk scenes from
endgame
they didn't say whether or not they
thought about doing a Valkyrie cameo
because she is queen of Asgard now more
likely that it would have been Corrigan
meek just because the class trip scenes
in the movie are meant to be comedic
scenes and those characters just work
better for that kind of energy plus if
you bring that Corrigan meek you can do
a follow up joke paying off that noob
Master fortnight reference during
Avengers endgame coorg finally wastes
noob master evil villain of Marvel phase
4 - this is a really big one early on
Anthony Mackie was supposed to have a
cameo as the brand-new version of
Captain America they didn't say what he
was supposed to have been doing or how
he would have helped spider-man during
the movie but in real life after they
revealed this Anthony Mackie went to
Twitter to complain blaming Tom Holland
for ruining the movie it's all your
fault I was supposed to be in this movie
those wings carbon-fibre this stuff
coming out of you I would explain the
rigidity flexibility ratio which gotta
say that's awesome I don't know if
you've been in a fight before but
there's usually not this much talk
alright sorry my bad I can't really
speculate more about where he would have
fit into the movie without talking about
more spoilery stuff that happens in the
second half so we'll just add that to my
videos next week when I start doing
Easter eggs and post credit scene videos
but number one this is a really big one
the director revealed that early on he
had wanted to do a live action version
of Miles Morales but what happened is is
they wound up doing him in spider-man
into the spider verse and because that
movie went so well and was so well
received the live-action spider-man MCU
producers just opted to wait on it until
they could do a movie where they could
fully devote their attention to
introducing miles instead of making it a
small cameo thing plus if you really
think about it Peter Parker isn't old
enough for Miles Morales to come around
traditionally miles doesn't get the
spider bite until Peter Parker in the
Ultimate Universe is a fully actualized
adult version of the character and right
now in the MCU Tom Hollands version of
the character is still a junior in high
school
so maybe Marvel phase 5 when spider-man
is in his 20s will start seeing Miles
Morales pop up and then they can do his
own spin-off franchise that things go
well let me know in the comments though
what is your favorite deleted scene so
far and once you do have a chance to see
the movie let me know what you wish they
had included in it if we learn about any
more really big deleted scenes or
anything that they were planning on
including in the movie originally I'll
do new videos about that but look out
for my post credit scene video in my
Easter eggs starting Tuesday probably
post credit scene first then I'll do
Easter egg the day after that be sure to
go see the movie it is very important to
the future of Marvel phase 4 and what's
going on in a larger sense with all
these characters absolutely mind-blowing
post-credit scene my next video will be
for that new avengers endgame
post-credit scene and the new deleted
scenes that they're tacking on to the
avengers endgame extended cut that
should post saturday morning
congratulations
Eduardo Lopez you're the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details click here for
that brand new taskmaster vs. black
widow teaser from the new avengers
endgame prequel movie and click here for
my non-spoilery spider-man far from home
review
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]